welcome to the program Myanmar Hunter
has admitted carrying out air strikes
that have killed at least 100 people the
attack happened on the village of basiji
and sanjin Province and is one of the
Hunter's deadliest since it seized power
in 2021 the un's human rights Chief says
it or he's horrified by the attacks
volca Turk said school children
performing dances at an event held by
opponents of the hunter are thought to
be amongst the victims Tony Chang is
following events for us from neighboring
Bangkok and Tony a really a startling
admission it sort of yet despite the
facts as we know them no sign of remorse
for the civilian casualties or sort of
any casualties for that matter from the
Hunter
absolutely none at all we saw the
statement made by Major General
zoomington broadcast on state television
last night he said that yes we launched
the airstrike we acknowledged that PDF
terrorists were killed during the
airstrikes he went on to say that there
were there was evidence of some wearing
uniforms that many were wearing what he
called civilian uniforms he also said
that some of the deaths weren't caused
according to information received by the
military by their airstrikes alone that
there was an ammunition dump nearby
maintained by the rebel militia that was
fighting against the military and he
said they had also laid landmines in the
area that could have caused many more
deaths we however have seen no evidence
of that the information that we've seen
on social media in videos and also
first-hand accounts we've got from First
Responders at the scene suggests this
was a mainly Sim civilian event that it
was held to celebrate the opening of
this administration building it had been
open to deal with social welfare and the
village Affairs of the neighboring areas
that outside there had been tables laid
out for the event and there were many
children there and that is certainly the
images that have been shown on social
media some of which are included in this
report but a warning that some viewers
may find those images very disturbing
rises in the aftermath of an airstrike
on passagee Village in Northern Myanmar
more than a hundred people had gathered
for the opening of an administration
building including many women and
children
napador sees buildings like this as
legitimate military targets as it tries
to tighten its hold on the country two
years after seizing power
at 7 45 in the morning fighter jets
attacked they were followed by mi-35
helicopter gunships
the initial death toll hard to gauge
many of the bodies disfigured in the
attack and rescue efforts hampered when
the gunships returned
we had to stop rescuing people in
retrieving bodies as they came back with
the helicopter at around 1pm and
attacked again three rescue workers died
in the attack now that the helicopter is
gone we are resuming retrieving the
bodies the attack seems to be one of the
worst since the military coup of 2021
and an indication that myanmar's
military sees little difference between
military and civilian targets
we strongly condone this kind of
atrocities by the military and against
the Suburbans we call that this
constitute is to work right by the
military because it's a violation of the
Geneva Convention Target in the
civilians and it's a part of the
military's politics to attack on the
communities of the people the Armed
Forces Day Parade last month the
military highlighted its air Power Jets
and helicopters have been used
increasingly to attack militias
resisting military rule around the
country
but the generals who command them seem
unconcerned by the civilians being
caught in the crossfire Tony Chang Al
Jazeera Bangkok
air power has become increasingly
important and used Far More Often by the
military since the military coup because
their troops are getting bogged down on
the ground all over the country in the
eastern border on the Western border and
up in the north but targeted sanctions
by the United States by the United
Kingdom and other nations particularly
trying to stop the type of fuel that
these fighter jets are using it doesn't
appear to be working there are
neighboring countries in this region
very happy to sell jet fuel to myanmar's
Military and we've seen not a no falling
back of use of airstrikes in fact in the
last couple of days the Myanmar military
planes have hit areas in chin state in
the west this attack and there have been
flybys on the eastern border as well so
those don't appear to be working I think
the insistence from the military as we
heard in their statement last night that
these are legitimate military tree
targets suggests that this isn't the
last time that a tragedy like this will
happen
Terry Chang in Bangkok thanks for the
update